thank you to brilliant for sponsoring
this video learn to code at
brilliant.org
simon clark the climate models used by
scientists to predict the future of our
planet's
climate are some of the most complicated
bits of code ever written
and they need serious hardware in order
to run
banks upon banks of super computing
power
necessary to complete the calculations
so what if you tried to do it on
something a little bit
simpler this is a raspberry pi 400
that was very kindly gifted to me by the
raspberry pi foundation to use in a
video
this is the latest in the line of
raspberry pi computers
and it's different from the previous
ones in the well it's a bit more
powerful it actually has a 64-bit
processor it's quad-core it even
supports 4k
video playback so it's it packs quite a
bit of a punch but most obviously it
actually has a keyboard built into the
computer so all you need to do is
plug in power and a mouse and a display
there's a hdmi port at the back
and away you go that's the computer this
tiny bundle has everything
in it in order to run computer code
which is mind-blowing to me that it's a
keyboard a keyboard is a computer
it comes with the operating system
preloaded on a micro sd card
look that that as a matter of fact i
actually still have my original
raspberry pi and the box from maplin
rip but this is what the original
raspberry pi was like there's a well
there's a rainbow case on it the actual
raspberry pi is just the circuit board
in this
and the hardware has come quite some
distance this thing only has 512
megabytes of memory
this has four gig and it's a keyboard
but i don't want to run something
simple like doom on this thing that's
way too easy what if we were to try
something a bit more complicated
like a climate model when i was your age
freddos was still
10p alright grandad it's been a long
locked down
getting code to run on a raspberry pi is
the simplest thing i've brought up a
text editor
and all i have to do is to write a
program in here let's do the simplest
one possible
so print hello world
and then save this as test dot py
py being a python file and then all i
have to do is
just click run and there you go it's
executed our program we've got the
output hello world
so can we get a program running on the
raspberry pi that will represent the
earth's climate
well the answer to that is definitely
yes because there are lots of different
types lots of different levels of
climate model
fundamentally all climate models are
based on the idea that an amount of
energy arrives at the earth from the sun
and then the earth emits a certain
amount of energy into space via thermal
radiation
and they're effectively just lots of
different layers of complexity on top of
that that allow you to make more and
more accurate models
so we can write a simple climate model
by taking that idea and boiling it down
to its bare components so what we could
do in this file is delete what we have
so far and let's declare a variable
called insulation which is just the
fancy name for the amount of energy
the earth receives from the sun and
let's say that this has a value of
1300 that's roughly the right amount for
the sun so this refers to the amount of
energy arriving at every square meter
of the earth per second so 1300 watts or
1300 joules per second
so how much energy does the earth
receive over a given period of time
well let's declare two new variables we
can have time which we can just use to
keep track of how long has elapsed
and then another variable which which we
could call earth energy this will
represent the total amount of energy in
the earth's system
the last variable we need is a time
increment or time
step which is basically how long passes
within our simulation between the
computer calculating how much energy
should be added to the system in this
particular case it won't be important
but in other simulations it becomes
very important and it's a balancing act
of how long you want the
program to take to run and how accurate
you want the program to be
i'm going to call that variable dt and
i'm going to set that to 60.
everything in this program is going to
be in standard units so that means 60
seconds
now all i need to do is write a little
loop this is while
true which basically means it's going to
go forever or until i tell it to stop
and then i just need to simply write
earth energy plus equals
so that means it stays the same but you
add whatever is to the right of the plus
equals sign to it
insulation times dt which if you recall
is the amount of energy that arrives per
second from the sun
multiplied by the number of seconds that
we're considering at a time in our
simulation and then very similarly time
plus equals dt and then so we can see
what's going on
i'm just going to write a little print
statement so print in other words
output time earth energy
hit save and then hit run
i don't know about you but i find that a
little bit difficult to work out what's
going on i find it a lot easier to
interpret information from
a figure or a plot rather than just a
stream of numbers unfortunately i'm not
an operator in the matrix
so let's add a plot to this which is
actually really simple we just need to
tell the pipe program that we want to
import a library and then i'm just going
to write a couple of lines of code which
will allow us to see the output of this
in real time okay i think this should
[Music]
work
one set fuzzy americans that's a you in
color damn it
okay i think this should work so here we
have a tiny little plot
sorry i'm running this on a big monitor
so it's a tiny little plot
and what you're seeing is the amount of
energy that is within the earth system
is adding up neatly over time the
further we go into the future the more
energy builds up at a
linear rate which is exactly what we
would expect also i didn't label my axes
let me just
fix that bad scientist bad the more
important thing we're missing however
from this is the energy that leaves the
earth the other side of that energy
balance equation
and that is governed by the really
simple black body radiation law
according to that law the amount of
energy that any object at a given
temperature emits is proportional
to the fourth power of that temperature
and we can write that in the code
really easily now this is where things
get interesting because
as the earth absorbs energy from the sun
it's going to warm up
and the warmer the earth gets the more
energy it will emit into space
and at some point those two amounts of
energy the amount it receives in the
amount it gives out will
be equal to each other and the earth
will be in equilibrium except you may
notice that we have been looking at
energy
not temperature and i'm not going to go
into the thermodynamics of this but
basically those two are related by
a physical constant which is the heat
capacity so
first of all i'm going to rename our
variable earth energy we don't want to
think in terms of energy anymore we want
to think in terms
of temperature i'm also going to define
a variable which
let's call heat capacity and i'm going
to set that equal to
1000 which obviously isn't an exact
figure but it's in the right ballpark
for the kind of experiment we're doing
here so the amount of energy that comes
in
from the sun is insulation and we have
to subtract from that
the black body radiation so we're going
to call our function and
the temperature that's going to go into
that is earth temperature
except we have to account for the
exchange rate between internal energy of
a system
and the temperature which is the heat
capacity so dividing this
by heat capacity and with a quick little
update to our plotting code
we should see this another tiny little
pla hang on let me
let me fix that so the earth's
temperature skyrockets from
zero and that's zero kelvin by the way
not zero degrees celsius or fahrenheit
or any other loopy land units you might
want to use
from zero kelvin to just under 400
kelvin so
that's 120 something degrees celsius so
this isn't necessarily the most
realistic model but more importantly
we're seeing that equilibrium between
the amount of energy that comes in from
the sun and the amount of energy that
leaves the earth due to thermal
radiation
however what we're not doing in this
experiment is accounting for the earth's
atmosphere which is obviously the main
thing we're interested in when we're
running a climate model to do that
we can write in a little bit of code
that represents the temperature of a
single
slab atmosphere so that's a single layer
that allows
short wavelength radiation from the sun
to pass through but
absorbs a certain fraction of long
wavelength radiation from the earth
so that represents the greenhouse effect
so adding in a couple of lines of code
to represent
that if we hit run now you'll notice
that the program's actually running a
bit slower because we're asking you to
do a few more calculations with every
time step
but you might also notice that the
temperature the earth is equilibrating
at is
a little bit higher that's because the
atmosphere is trapping heat that would
otherwise be lost to space
in the earth's system and we can dial in
how effectively it does this with the
emissivity parameter so
if i change this from 0.1 to say 0.5
and that would be a really absorptive
atmosphere so
loads of co2 loads of methane and water
vapor in the air
then run the program again
and you can see that the earth
equilibrates originally but then it
heats
up the atmosphere and that warmed up
atmosphere then
allows for the earth underneath to heat
up that little bit more so now
the equilibrium temperature here is over
400 kelvin so
that's maybe 150 degrees celsius
of course this is fantastically
simplistic because the atmosphere
doesn't behave as a single
slab a single entity it gets thinner the
higher you get up it has
different layers in it that behave
slightly differently we can represent
that in code using multiple
layers of atmosphere and a for example a
gray radiation scheme something a bit
more complicated than what we're doing
at the moment
but even that is still ignoring the
elephant in the room which is that this
is all
a one-dimensional model we're assuming
one point that receives the same amount
of sunshine at all times and that
represents the entire planet and that's
obviously not true
the equator receives more energy from
the sun than the poles
that night exists there are areas of the
earth that receive
no radiation from the sun whatsoever
when it's night time to represent this
you need a global circulation model or
gcm
which are phenomenally complicated bits
of
code to represent the global circulation
how
wind moves around the entire planet
redistributing heat and moisture and
all kinds of things these are the kinds
of models that are used by climate
institutes to
predict what's going to happen into the
future they're also used by weather
agencies to predict what the weather's
going to be in the coming weeks
now unfortunately i don't have access to
a full gcm
like the met office or nowhere might use
because those are trade secrets
however there is another source another
[Music]
gcm
[Music]
this is claude climate analysis using
digital estimations
a bacronym coming from our discord
server's mascot and this is a gcm that
i've been coding for the past
several months over on my twitch streams
by the way if you have
amazon prime you automatically have one
free twitch subscription to give away
via prime gaming which
doesn't cost you anything and gives me
sorry
i mean a twitch channel money for free
so i'm just gonna leave this link
right here in the description
claude is designed to be incredibly
customizable so you can specify
a custom resolution whether that's in
the horizontal grid the vertical
grid or even in time and you can choose
any number of parameters so you could
pick a planet with a
huge axial tilt no axial tilt with a
very dim
star that it orbits or a very bright
star that it orbits or you could change
it to
be a rapidly spinning planet or a
tidally locked planet i pop the code
onto a memory stick which you can plug
into the back of the raspberry pi
and i've got it set up here in the text
editor there are bits of this which is
still experimental
and are going to slow it down but with
that said let's see how the raspberry pi
can deal with this
so for reference when i'm running this
on my computer these kind of parameters
it will take
maybe two seconds to actually do the
calculations
perhaps another second on top of that to
do the plotting for a given time step
so let's see how um let's see how this
does so let's also account for
the spin up so we won't load
in a save file so send that to false
and then that's boogie run
so i've also included little timers in
this so it will tell us how long it
takes for each time step
and that's um it's slower
let's expand this a bit so we can see
what's going on so so far it's taking
about 2.7
seconds to do the actual radiation
for reference i'm just going to run this
on my computer now that would take about
0.6 seconds
but now we're running into the real meat
so now what it's doing is calculating
the velocities
at given points in the atmosphere and
also the direction so those velocities
moving quantities like heat around
in the atmosphere and that's taking
about 12
seconds so this is actually i'm
quite surprised this is only four
maybe five times slower than
my big beefy computer that i edit on
which perhaps indicates that i just need
to optimize the code a bit better
multi-threading i really need to do
multi-threading but i have to say
it's actually running claude
just fine i i hadn't done this before
this video
and one of the things with claude is
that i've written it such that anybody
could download it and anybody can run it
on their machine
um i wasn't entirely sure how effective
that would be
but it turns out you could literally run
it on a raspberry pi
on a keyboard on a bloody keyboard
that's quite an amazing piece of kit
like to be able to right here on this
tiny little keyboard you're running a
climate model
like a gcm with advection and convection
and a
three-dimensional earth that's pretty
pretty great i thought this thing would
be taking off
it doesn't even have fans and i somehow
thought it would still be taking off
from the
desk of course claude is not a full gcm
this is still missing so many facets of
the earth's
climate like the different feedbacks
that take place ice albedo feedback
moisture vapor feedback clouds orography
there's
so many different aspects that aren't
accounted for yet
and we're going to be adding them over
the coming weeks and months
over on my twitch streams if you want to
catch the development of this live it's
every wednesday evening
at least for me in the uk on my twitch
twitch.tv forward slash
simon clark and you can download the
code yourself and have a play
on my github there'll be a link in the
description to the project
do bear in mind if you do so that you
will need to install some libraries like
syphon
and it is a work in progress the model
will almost certainly blow up on you
within like a day it's a work in
progress
if this all seems interesting to you but
you've never programmed before
there's no better place to learn than
the python course on
brilliant who have kindly sponsored this
video their beautifully illustrated and
interactive course on python takes you
from the absolute basics to
giving you all the tools necessary to
write your own programs
and if you enjoy the introductory course
on python they have many others in the
field of computer science from the
fundamentals of algorithms and data
structures to advanced topics such as
the workings of search engines and
machine learning
brilliant is all about learning by doing
giving you interactive problems and
encouraging you to experiment and learn
from your mistakes when you get stuff
wrong
it's basically how school should be
perhaps you're looking at this and
thinking this would be a great gift for
a student in your life
supporting their learning in school or
college well you're in luck
you can gift access to brilliant premium
with more than 60 high quality
educational courses at the link below or
get it as a present for yourself
either way the first 200 subscribers to
go to brilliant.org
simon clark will get 20 off their
subscription
and get access to a truly brilliant
educational resource
thank you for watching the video and of
course thank you so much to the
raspberry pi foundation for sending me
this
amazing piece of kit again i am
astonished
that it ran the code as well as it did
if you have any suggestions for what i
could do with this bit of kit
next then do let me know because i i'd
love to play around with this thing more
also if you'd like to see the grand
pappy the original raspberry pi try and
run claude then let me know and i think
that could be arranged in a future video
if you would like to see more of claude
then do check out those twitch streams
and you can download the code yourself
at the github repository link in the
description
if you enjoyed the video then please do
pop it a like share it with your friends
you're a grown adult you
probably know what you're doing by this
point actually who am i kidding i don't
here's some suggested viewing next and
if you enjoyed the video and you're not
already then you know you can subscribe
to the channel that'd be nice
anyway thanks again for watching i'll
see you in the next one
you